so the reason a lot of the reason that
monogamy is pushed is because it's good
for society and it is good for society
it's good for society as a whole to have
a man a woman a family they're together
the man provides for the woman Etc the
government doesn't want to pay for all
these kids if you don't have child
support he's paying for these kids the
government does it it breaks down right
so that's why child support is enforced
in many parts of the world in certain
other parts of the world child support
isn't enforced because they have
religious beliefs or genuine genuine
family beliefs that keep the families
together but in the Western World now
you need child support because you've
broken things down to the point where
men don't want to be married to chicks
chicks don't want to listen to the man
the man can't even be the man in his own
household he can't even feel respected
where he goes his woman gives her him no
status and and now he doesn't want to
[ __ ] deal with her anymore so how do
you get that kid paid for well then tell
the man or you go to jail the news come
along with a [ __ ] long arm of the law
and you [ __ ]